some of what people have said before but
I think these are things that need to be
repeated so I don't feel bad about it
um okay so what's this talk about so um
it's a talk about logic
um because I guess most of us understand
logic but it's also a talk about
something more important than logic so
of course we all know Tony as a
mathematician and there have been lots
of talks and lots of stories about how
inspirational she is and how her work is
um but when I think of Tony I also think
of um the personal aspect and her
qualities as a person and her sort of
emotional intelligence which allows her
to work with people with so many
different abilities
um levels of experience personalities
and so on which I think is quite
extraordinary
um and the way she has of Bridging the
Gap of being sort of sensitive and
empathetic to the person behind the
mathematician
um so I think that's that's something
really special she meets people on equal
terms um so
um she almost always knows more than one
but it's but you never get the sense for
talking to her there's always a sense
that one has something to contribute in
a discussion
um so I think that's a very special
skill as well that there's no sense of
hierarchy in working with her so um so
so these are all sort of important
things and for me her mathematical work
is sort of interwoven with these sort of
personal qualities so I'm going to try
to capture at least a little bit of that
in my talk without separating the two
out completely
so let's see how it goes
um so okay so when I say a theory of
Tony CS what is the theory so I'd like
it to mean any and or all of these
things so theory is of course what we
all practice in a manner of speaking
because we did a computer scientist I
mean that's sort of like the dictionary
definition where it's some sort of
system of ideas in trying to explain
something I mean I don't think I can
really explain Tony on her works but I
can at least try to sort of organize
what uh my experience of it is and and
then there's of course a logical
definition of a theory which came up
when there's a sort of boundary
arithmetic reading group here at Simon's
and and Tony was talking I mean there's
this whole discussion of whether a
theory is a set of sentences or you also
need it to be close on logical
consequence I think I like the
definition that's just as their
sentences because it makes being a
terrorist easier I think I can live up
to it more easily in this talk so just
think of the stock as a set of sentences
and you'll be fine
okay so what am I going to do so I only
have half an hour so I don't have that
much time so um the way the stock has
been organized is through just some
basic concepts that you might all be
aware of um familiar with and maybe to
see these in a somewhat new light so
we're talking about completeness
induction models proofs relations
so completeness first
um so we heard earlier in this Workshop
in noriko's talk she um uh was uh asking
about Tony's favorite mathematical
theorem and um yeah we heard that Tony's
favorite game was a completeness theorem
for first order logic but then the
question arises what does this say about
her and her career
um well it says something what her can
do attitude I said anything that's true
can be proven
um
and my favorite theorem is the
incompetence theorem it came forward
but this is going to be about Tony
um so uh I went back and looked at
Tony's work and I was trying to like
draw together various themes so so um
like if you look at her kind of like
research program in a career um from now
I mean like what's uh what sort of teams
emerge and and there are several that
sort of come up and first of course are
these sort of long-term research
programs so that the kind of the
questions that Tony kind of like learned
about Russia's graduate students the
questions I see in fundamental then
she's been concerned with ever since
right so the the project of to improve
complexity low balance for a variety of
systems for variance of resolution
cutting planes no strandsads with Paul
and Russell and others bonded Fragger
lower Shriver stabbing planes so um this
sort of um like project of crewing low
balance for proof complexity which is a
fundamental problem has been something
that's occupied all along and then
there's a theme of automatability which
we heard about in Maria's talk uh so
there's a sort of seminal paper of
Christchurch and putlock but then
several of the following works by Maria
and Tony and others on tc0 Fragger
bounded apps Fragger with his work with
Sam and others and MP hardness of proof
size which is closely related then
Tony's really cool work on connection
between learnability and automatability
which hasn't really been followed up
very much but I think it's a really cool
connection then following on Albert's
work with Elizabeth some some work on
weak automatically of depth 3 Fragger
more recently following that serious
model of paper or natural black systems
cutting planes you can see that that one
Stoney gets onto a problem she thinks
about it for years for decades on end
and kind of like remains engaged with it
because these are fundamental problems
and she's interested in the hard
problems fundamental problems and then
of course there's lifting which I'm not
as qualified to talk about but you heard
about some of that from Paul Stock
um starting with the paper with Paul and
Trin I mean there's a sort of vast
theory of lifting that she's developed
with Mika and Robert and others
um so there's a lot in proof
conversation we don't understand but at
least for the things that we do
understand we can try to understand it
really really well and to kind of make
this really rich map of connections
between queries and communication
between circuits and proofs and so on so
it's a really beautiful Theory so
there's all of these things but it's not
just that I mean Tony is always open to
bridging
um with uh people that she comes into
contact with them with working with them
so in particular I mean things that I'm
aware of collaborations with Toronto
postdocs such as arkadev I mean archive
came in an interesting communication
complexity it's something that only
worked with him on Josh groshak told us
about
um how he was interested in algebraic
complexion and Tony met him halfway with
that and I was more interested in
structural complexity and conditional
complexity and that's kind of what we
kind of like um worked on together
and there's always a sense I mean of
course it's about including us and about
connecting to us but it's also about
some of expanding proof complexity
because then these tools these ideas
come into proof complexity make proof
complexity are richer and um and and
more significant field I think so um so
so this serves multiple purposes and
then there are other Explorations which
I can't really like uh capture within
this I mean so maybe a sense of
adventure differential privacy with
Cynthia and her work with Rich and
fairness and Theory machine learning
um maybe somewhere Tony said these are
connected proof complexity too I don't
know but uh but uh yeah but but I think
it's just um very useful for for someone
who's starting off to think about like
the various ways in which you can kind
of like form a research vision and and
um kind of a combination of like a
longer term research program questions
that you care about all the way through
and then opportunities that you have in
terms of meeting people halfway and
connecting with them
um and then trying to keep things fresh
and interesting for yourself and um
having these kind of maybe intellectual
Adventures or that's what I think of
them as things so uh so that's about
completeness um so induction is next
um and this is going to be a bit more
personal because it's going to be about
my own induction to prove complexity at
Toronto
um so um so what happened was that I
arrived in Toronto as the post talk in
2007 I done a PhD at Chicago and then I
was with Valentin
um at Simon Fraser for a bit at the same
time as Josh Beres schopenheim and I'd
only been doing completion complexity I
hadn't I don't have a clue about roof
complexity so that's the um so when I
arrived in Toronto I mean there's this
like great Theory group at Toronto I
imagine working mostly with Steve and
with Charlie rakoff um I did work a bit
with Steve and that led I think
eventually to this windfall that uh that
James and Ian have 100 went for but um
so so there's some work in that
direction I talked a lot to Charlie but
not the easiest person to collaborate
with but I enjoy the conversations with
him uh in the end it was Tony who had
the most influence on me and my work um
so what she did was that she suggested
that I use my intuitions about
competition complexity as a guide when
learning and doing proof complexity
um and like there's a sort of um this
thing mentioned earlier in the workshop
about how the first problem you meet
sort of imprints you right so like like
somehow you continue thinking about it
all the way along and it's been like
that with my first experience with proof
complexity this idea of connections
between circuit complexion computational
complexion proof complexity has been
something that's concerned me ever since
um and I think that's because of this
kind of initial sort of interaction with
Tony
um and let me just say a little bit
about what we did so our first kind of
paper together this was announced still
a postdoc Toronto or immediately
afterward
um so we kind of like try to Define like
a new emotional stimulation and proof
complexity which was actually heavily
influenced by work of power and and
Maria and Albert so the standard notion
of a simulation proof complexity is
where a system a simulates the system B
for every formula
um there's some polynomial time
algorithm that Maps B proofs to a proofs
right so in particular if there's a
short B proof there's also going to be a
short a
output a proof of size polynomial in the
size of this B proof
um so that's the standard notion of
simulation and then one of the
fundamental questions of proof
complexity is for various pairs of proof
systems does one simulate the other or
not so Sam talked about fragr versus EF
I mean are there even good candidates
for assists for for can for formulas
that are short cruising here but not
with Fragger so that's Fragger piecing
late EF that's one of the big questions
in our field
um so for most natural pairs of proof
systems A and B um let's say that b is
at least as strong as a it simulates a
it seems likely that a doesn't seem late
b as long as we haven't found a
simulation so far maybe there is a
separation
but as we well know if you've tried to
prove compression low balance it's often
very hard to show
so what we did was well I mean the
typical kind of serious strategy with a
hard question right changed the question
so we considered a sort of relaxed
notion of simulation
um and we have this notion of an
effective peace simulation which somehow
makes more sense from the point of view
of computational complexity which is
that
um you don't really require that every
formula in B has like short proofs and a
all you require is that for every
formula in B there's some other formula
in a that a has short proofs off that's
sort of like equivalent to the original
B formula right so there's like an
efficient truth preserving algorithm
which means that it Maps like a
tautologies to tautologies and not
projects not topologies such as when m
is at least a size the shortest B proof
of fee that's kind of like a slight
technical condition let's not worry
about that for now then R of V comma m
is an a proof of a so you're allowed to
somehow pre-process this formula Phi or
change it and then you'll have to prove
that in a instead
so um essentially what a needs to do is
just to prove a formula that's
equivalent to fee efficiently rather
than fee itself
um so I mean yeah so it's not that
natural from the point of view of proofs
perhaps but it is Nashville's the point
of view of proof search because from the
point of view of proof search and
looking for proofs this kind of
simulation is sufficient it's um if a
has efficient proof search and uh a
effectively P similar to B then B has a
vision proof search as well
um and we gave several examples of
non-trivial effective peace simulations
linear resolution and resolution
resolution K resolution and Clause
learning and resolution and so on so
this is a setting in which it's possible
to get simulations where you can't get
simulations but we don't know how to get
simulations in the standard setting
um well and then we can ask about the
low Bond question can we hope to show
that a does not effectively please
simulate B for systems A and B
um and there's kind of like a simple
proposition that of MP equals P then
every pair of cool systems uh a
effectively peace similar to B so what
does this mean this means now that we
have good excuse for not being able to
Show Low bounds because that was
separate npnp so we went both ways
simulations are kind of richer and uh as
for the possibility of simulations
that's harder to prove so we don't need
to worry about it
um we can however still hope for
separations under restricted form
reductions and I think that's something
that's interesting that maybe there can
be further work on so this is my kind of
like first work with Tony I mean yeah
it's
um mostly observations but it's it's
really something that kind of brought me
into proof my question got me more
familiar with the Notions so that was my
introduction to proof complexity
okay then uh the notion of a model so
that's a third concept
um
and of course what I like to talk about
is Tony is a role model so um so yeah
from a variety of points of view
um so the point of view of sociality so
um yeah one of the most exciting things
for me um coming to Toronto is that
there's so many people to talk to there
um so I mean at Simon phrase I had one
team to talk to and that was great at
Chicago I learned how to nobody
um because you're expected to be
self-reliant there and a Toronto is a
complete opposite you learn how to talk
to everybody and somehow by
interpolating between these you'll learn
to be somewhat social as a researcher so
I think it's good to be in different
environments and kind of um and learn
different skills and for those of you
who are students here at Simon's I mean
Simons is a naturally social player so
I'd really urge you to take advantage of
that fully uh and I think a big part of
the social care Toronto was Tony because
she and amner were like really like hubs
of the I mean um the main group that
have been built up by Alan and Steve but
then Tony and Abner were very very
active in interacting with students and
postdocs and there's a really great
atmosphere I mean we were in the Sanford
Fleming building which is not the most
inspiring
to be in because of people there yeah
the uh social sociality
does that have the same relation to
social ability as automatizability it
has to Auto disability
that's a controversial question just
judging by everything that's happened so
far
yeah so social peace sociability yeah uh
I think it's gonna be hard to understand
um okay the second thing um is
multitasking because um like ever since
I've known Tony she's been great at like
making time for her students in the
postdocs but she's always had a lot on
her plate um and I think like the older
I get the more senior I get the more I
understand why that's the case but it's
sort of like inspirational how in the
time that she had she was able to use it
to the Max and in kind of like um in
kind of communicating ideas and
directions and so forth I mean maybe
kind of writing a paper on a drive on
the highway is a bit extreme but
otherwise I think the muscle is asking
is a good idea
um can I uh can I add to that
can you hear me yeah
yeah I was gonna say kind of one of the
things that amazed me about Tony's
multitasking is that when she is meeting
with you you don't feel like she's
multitasking you don't realize that she
has a dozen other things going on the
rest of her day like it feels like oh
yeah she's been working on your project
the whole time right and yet somehow she
has like dozens of things going on at
once and it's just amazing yeah yeah
yeah I mean I think where Tony is with
you she's completely present and I think
that's yeah that's that's one of the the
the nicest aspects I mean in terms of
the sociality of sociality for example I
like I I mean I know that Tony isn't
naturally the most extroverted person
and he actually manages to be quite
social so that's kind of like a model
for me because I I think I'm quite
introverted too in some ways so um it's
uh yeah but but the main thing is to be
completely present when you are with
someone and and that Tony has always
been in a research conversations
um and then of course I mean Tony's more
distinct so you saw yesterday that she's
very reluctant to talk about herself
um and that's sort of like genuine and
comes from from deep down but it also
has this other function that means that
she's never sort of complacent to rest
on a laurel and she's always about the
next new problem or like learning
something new and I think that's
inspirational too the center there's
always something left to do um and uh
one can't quite just um sit back and be
comfortable and then finally
um well this is of course a term that
less Valiant popularized but it has
nothing to do with lessons notion so
evolvability and what do I mean by that
so I was thinking of something very
specific which is um presentation so
this is a presentation and um to be
honest I'm quite embarrassed in general
by my presentations because I mean I'm
not as harsh on myself as you all is but
let's say my presentations are low-tech
let's let's call them low-tech to be
polite and um for a long time I was okay
with this because Tony's presentations
were low Tech too and I thought if if
that was the case with her then they
could it was fine for it to be the case
with me and then a few years ago she
learned how to use the tablet and she's
drawing like these beautiful pictures
and getting these great talks and I felt
very abandoned but uh but but but also
inspired I mean it's maybe not such a
good idea for me to give talks to my
tablet if anyone want to see my
handwriting but maybe there are other
ways
um okay so that's about uh being a role
model uh Max the notion of proof
um so yeah so let's talk about real
world proofs and I don't mean once that
are done by sat solvers but ones that
are done by us humans proofs in our area
so if the three projects I've been
involved with but with Tony by far the
most labor intensive in many ways was
this one or serial termism which um was
with Shafi and Russell and Tony
um and uh it's a project but I also
think of it as a virus and
um there's a mathematical virus that
maybe I'd like to help spread uh at this
at this event
um already arcadev said a bit about it
um and I think it might be good to just
kind of repeat a little bit of the
framework and then tell you some stories
about what happened with this project so
um so what's your relatively query
complexity so you have this this
question there's a total search problem
um let us be the first problem and we
say it has student very complexity queue
there's a randomized query algorithm
which makes at most Q queries and
outputs of fixed solution to a search
problem with the probability at least
two-thirds let's say
um so one example I think I think this
isn't one that they've covered is output
a 0.1 additive approximation to a
fraction of ones in the input string
right so this notion of Serial terms
then there's a beautiful notion that
Shafi and Iran Dart came up with and
then as we started in various contexts
and one of the things that's been proved
about it in the query setting there's
this paper by goldray gold was not wrong
and they showed that this problem has um
complexity Omega n so it requires Omega
n complexity and it's easy to see just
by random sampling that you can get
um kind of like an answer that's within
point one just by making constant number
of queries but not the same answer each
time if you want to produce the same
number with on most competition parts
that requires query complexity Omega n
and that's a sort of a hybrid argument
so it's a nice argument but it's not too
hard to show
and then you might think well let's
change the problems slightly
um and let's ask for this kind of like a
solution just find one's problem so
given an end with input with at least n
over two ones can you output the index
of one right so okay operate the index
of sum one
and this is a problem that's an FNP in
the query World unlike the other problem
you can actually check the solution
because if you're given an R you can go
and look at x i and check that it's
actually one there's something you can't
do with that problem of approximating
the Hamming weight
um so it's interesting to look at
problems in FNP and whether you can
separate randomized and see your terms
are very complexity for those problems
um the randomized query complexities
again or one because you can just output
a random index and that's likely to be
good with high probability
um and the trivial exhaustive search
algorithm um is a deterministration
which requires query complexity like
Omega n because you might keep
encountering zeros you look at the
string from beginning to end and you
awkward the first one and it seems hard
to come up with the zero toxic algorithm
that does much better than that I mean
that seems to be the best um that we
seem to be able to do
um so um well what we showed um and this
again repeating what ocular said is it
find Once requires very complexity Omega
square root n and there's a sort of
surprisingly indirect proof I mean it
requires a detour through the Notions as
proof system the application of Huang
sensitivity theorem and so on well the
one Saving Grace it's optimal for
Quantum query algorithms so it's optimal
for something but it's not quite the
bound you want to get so what about the
true Omega event bound
so it's kind of like connected to this
kind of graph theoretic problem is very
very natural right so you consider like
a coloring of the middle two layers say
of the N Cube and you take a vertex and
you color it by some I so in arbitrary
coloring such that what is colored by
some I such that the I bet is one right
so if it's say you have like the first
no two bits or zeros the next no two
bits or once the color can be any of the
uh anything green no two plus one and
and N right so that's an N coloring um
the N card is reconsider and the
question is is there some vertex V in
these middle two layers such as this
neighborhood as Omega event colors so
it's a neighborhood is very
polychromatic
um and we'd like to show that such a
Vertex exists and if we do then we would
get a linear pseudo terms to query uh
low bound so I mean that seems that it
should be the case and uh uh yeah but
yeah but we just weren't able to prove
it and um so maybe at this point it
helps to say a little bit about how uh
this problem was introduced to me and
what happened after that so so um it
this problem was actually I mentioned to
be offer Grossman who's a student of
Shar phase and I think he had thought
about it and it seemed very simple at
first and it was um sort of like he
thought an information Theory argument
should do it but it didn't really give
him much oh yes do you mean this was
introduced no no defined ones the fine
ones yeah so offer arrested me in 2018
and he taught me I would find once and
he said there should be an information
theoretic kind of like arguments on this
but we don't know it's very surprising I
agree it was surprising but I did get
quite infected by the virus until I came
here for the science program 2018 and
then we talked with the Shafi and Tony
and I talked about it and um we had some
kind of progress towards it I mean
independently I think Russell had a way
of combining like known kind of query
sort of relations together one fourth
bound which is also into the one third
or close to N to the one third but then
there's this question of trying to get
closer to um to Mega n and at some point
I don't remember whether it was the end
of the science program or maybe shortly
afterwards there was a square or 10
argument I think that's really due to
Tony um but then then we were kind of
like trying to work further on on
improving it and I have all these emails
in my inbox I mean like hundreds of them
actually we've worked on it for months
on end um and Tony would send me all
these ideas we kind of like tried kind
of graph theoretic methods and algebraic
methods and spanners Lemma and uh
Fourier and Arctic methods and uh yeah
every yeah everything that we could
think of and I still haunted by the idea
that there's some in one of those emails
there's an idea I didn't probably follow
up the natural solution but
um yeah but I don't know but I think
it's um a really really great problem
um and uh I would encourage you to
sacrifice yourself to be infected by
this virus once and for all um
[Music]
um
on the other hand I mean like huang's um
sort of sensitivity theorem that's like
such a beautiful proof and it was only
done recently maybe there's some really
beautiful proof of this um we need to
wait and see so there's this sort of
like story earlier about the cycling
pathologies and how there's like this
this sort of uh Enterprise for a very
long time and trying to prove the lower
bound against cutting planes and it
failed but there was a good reason for
that feeling because it was false but
here is probably true so we don't have
as good reason
one of the two
um okay and then finally about the the
notion of relation
um and I think here
um yeah so so many people approve
compressive community and Beyond Tony is
like a collaborator mentor and friend
um so yeah that's so valuable in many
different ways
um
um and she's perhaps I mean the most
generous and enabling of collaborators I
know and I mean given how collaborative
she is and how influential her work has
been and proof complexity I I was kind
of like had this thought experimenters
could we Define like a potassium number
for research it's a proof complexity a
distance in a collaboration graph from
her
um then thought about it a bit and I was
like this isn't so interesting because
suppose we pick a random paper
Improvement complexity and a random
author on this paper the high
probability the author will have
potassium back most one
so it's kind of like trivializes the
notion it might not be so interesting to
consider
but uh it's quite extraordinary how much
Tony you're able to connect with people
and draw them into into proof complexity
um and of course it's been a very sort
of valuable mentor and friend it's
harder to talk about because it's more
personal but she's always been present
um whenever uh we needed her I mean also
in organizing this program yeah Russell
I think we could have like a competition
where instead of people competing to
have a low potassium number you see like
if anybody has a high one that's really
hard yes what is the diameter of the
crap yeah that's a much better question
um so yeah I mean so just to conclude I
mean like thanks Tony for all your
mathematical lessons and all your life
lessons and thanks for being a
collaborator for being a mentor and most
of all for being a friend
[Applause]
what a great talk to wrap up on uh any
questions
Russell again
so I think I came in on at least on the
writing of that paper when uh
the work had already been done it didn't
quite seem that
uh I didn't spend that much of an effort
on that paper compared to other things
but I want to say but since then like I
spent wasted a lot of time on this
problem
um and I think it's like a general
comment uh and I think what you were
saying agrees with it is that in my life
I've spent
uh a lot of effort in mathematics
failing
and the ratio of time I've spent failing
the time I've spent succeeding is
immense so it's much more work to fail
to solve a problem than to succeed and I
think you were saying the same thing
yeah yeah absolutely and I should say
that with this mathematical virus will
it try to infect as many people as
possible we told are we witnessing and
Mike Stacks about it but they're very
skilled at evading these viruses so they
didn't succumb but maybe maybe someone
here would
thinking of one story I don't know if I
should say so uh I don't know if uh so
in Toronto students we had the CRT
student seminar I think it's still
running and the rule was that
faculty were only allowed the explicit
admination of the speaker I don't know
if it's still the case
but it might have a Toronto I can't
remember faculty ever being invited in
fact
so when Tony came and to Toronto and
found about the theory students in nurse
says but how can I how can I not come I
still feel like a student that's exactly
what you said
and for longest time I think it was the
only honorary student that was allowed
finally like decided
that explains why you see everybody's
not equal if I think for yourself as a
student well it was fun you know it was
that was her so I just wanted to thank
the organizers and everybody for yeah an
amazing like three days yeah it was like
really shocking and amazing so thanks so
much
yeah I guess on that uh let's thank
Rahul again and move to the closing
remarks
okay uh shopping do you have something
you need to say at the end
oh okay never mind
[Laughter]
all right well first there has been uh
before this intractable problem that has
been solved that I want to announce
which is uh what is the afternoon
activity and uh that we were planning on
a hike originally but then the the
weather hit so we thought that we should
keep our options open and when we told
the satony of course she wasn't deterred
and said oh yeah let's go on a hike so
at 2 30 we're going to meet in the lobby
and then we're going to uh walk
somewhere so uh bring good uh shoes and
jacket and whatnot
um yeah other evening things uh there
will still be a music night at six
o'clock tonight and I really thank you
oh yeah wait thank you Shafi so much for
all your help yeah
done a lot to the point of even offering
us her house for the yesterday's party
but the weather interfered and without
you we won't have this party yes but we
won't have the workshop to begin with
thank you so much yes thank you so much
[Applause]
so yes uh there will also be people
going to Pub trivia at seven a number of
people have asked me about this it will
be at uh Bobby G's Pizzeria which is at
the corner of University and Shattuck uh
but and there's also the there's the uh
before that uh music night how many
people would show up if you have it
yay okay the music night's on Perfect
all right and now of course to the
thanks uh thank you for catching Chelsea
before she left uh of course first and
foremost it's uh Simon's for giving us
the venue and the budget and everything
for this incredible event uh to the
events and operations staff who've been
dealing with us the whole time Drew
Kevin William Ashley Elizabeth Sandy oh
man I mean and uh yeah the tech staff in
general for making sure that all the uh
the mics and the zoom and whatnot run
smoothly uh Shafi of course for offering
your house and for helping with the
banquet Arrangements uh Ellie for
catering it yesterday and the custodial
staff for making sure that this place
always looks great so let's thank them
real quick
[Applause]
all right and now for the
acknowledgments section uh uh Maria
Luisa for uh helpful discussions uh and
uh Russell of course for helpful
discussions and that beautiful song that
we had the other day uh Maria Clau for
doing the amazing uh painting of Tony
but we gave us the gift yesterday and
Paul and Anne for taking care of the
framing of it uh of course I want to
thank all of the speakers thank you so
much for coming out and making this
event so great and to everyone who
attended uh especially those who were
invited and uh came who I think a lot of
us haven't seen in two three or many
more years so thanks for coming to make
this event like really really special
and of course the last Thanks goes to
Tony for all that you do for the
community and for bringing us together
[Applause]
thank you so much Ian for doing the Lion
Share of work and coming up with school
stuff and being amazing thank you a true
Tony student and thank you to Angelina
kolokolova our head organizer
all right and with that we are going to
conclude the technical part of Tony CS
uh so we have now an hour and a half for
lunch and if you want to reconvene here
for the hike then we will see you then
thanks
um